hi guys I'm Angela from simply learn now
if you have been following our playlist
on Python by now you have probably
completed all the basic concepts of
Python so today we'll use these basic
concepts in creating a website using
Python again now this application is
called Django and before we move into
actually developing the website let's
better understand what Django is so
Django is a high-level Python web
framework so when you compare Django to
many of its other counterparts such as
flask which also uses peyten it provides
very limited freedom but then again this
limited freedom does mean that it makes
development much faster and that is the
goal of jungle so if you are a complete
beginner with web development and also
sort of with Python this is the place to
start so django has a free and a paid
version but since you are just learning
how it works we can go for the free
version in fact the paid version is only
required when it's utilized by companies
where they perform a lot of
modifications to the point that it's
actually unrecognizable now some of the
companies which are using Django our
Instagram bitbucket Pinterest and even
NASA now this another important thing
that we need to understand about Django
which is its design pattern so Django
follows the MTV design pattern where MTV
stands for model template view these
terms may seem very remote to you right
now and I don't think there'd be a point
of me explaining what they are as of now
so once we move on to the demo where
I'll be teaching how you can create the
web framework we can better understand
how this design pattern works and with
that we are finally ready to move into
actually creating our website so there
are certain prerequisites to Django to
perform these open your command prompt
so the first thing we need to ensure is
that a system has Python installed now
of course if we are learning Django you
probably already know Python and for
this purpose you would have had Python
installed previously itself we'll just
checked so type in python version and if
you do have Python installed your
version number will appear here now the
other thing we need installed is script
so once again pip would also be
installed on your systems it comes with
Python itself and so yeah I have pepper
19-point 0.2 version now once those two
things are done we'll move on to a
virtual environment so a virtual
environment is basically this
environment that we create to isolate
our application now this is necessary in
Django because often we make
applications we have completely built
the application and now we do not want
to touch them we do not want to create
anything new we do not want to update
any packages that are already being used
so if you are creating a new application
for which you need to update the
packages we don't want the
implementation of that to hamper with
the implementation of a current
application so this is why we completely
isolate them so for that the first thing
you do is you need to install the
virtual environment wrapper
we'll use the pipe command to do so so
pip install watch E and V wrapper if
you're using any other system such as
Linux systems and then press Enter but
in case of windows put a dash and win
which signifies windows so I already
have my virtual environment installed so
now we have Python we have our pipe and
we have the virtual environment now
let's create a virtual environment so to
create the virtual environment type in
MK virtual env and the name for your
virtual environment so previously I had
made a virtual environment py one this
time I'll go with py 2 and that should
create your environment so a virtual
environment is created which is P by 2
and as soon as it's created you'll
notice that now your command start
running in py 2 so when you're creating
an application the application itself is
not created at this place it's just the
environment files that's stored in here
so now all this is done the final
prerequisite is of course to have our
web framework we need to install Django
so let's get to that with install Django
so now the Django is installed we are
finally ready to start our project for
the command to run to start your first
project
Django - admin start project and
followed by the name of your project so
I'll just name my project the Django
project so I just cleared my screen now
if you go to this location where we
created our project you'll see the
project folders created here and inside
the 4
yet another folder with the same
projecting and a managed file now this
managed file is usually what we will be
running to compile our programs and then
within the folder you have certain
Python files so we'll open all this in
our ID and I'll be using
PyCharm but you can go ahead with any
other Python ID in fact you can even use
a notebook so you can select your
project from here the panel on the left
or you can opt for open browse through
your folders and then select your
project so the project we created just
now is the Django project which is this
one so I'll open it and and your project
will appear on the left side panel here
we can see within it there's another
folder with the same project name and
they see manage dot py file now within
this folder again there's another folder
dot idea and then there is the init
Settings URL and the WSGI file although
we won't be making changes or modifying
any of these files so we'll check out
what these files are one by one although
we won't be making modifications to most
of them the idea folder probably won't
be existing in your project you can
completely ignore that now we'll have a
look at what each of these Python files
do so the first file which is the init
file as you can see it's empty the
reason is that the very presence of this
file is only to inform that this package
here this is not any ordinary folder
it's a Python package so you don't
really need any content within this now
the next file that we have here is this
settings file so the settings file is
essential configuration file this is
modified only when your application goes
into the real world other than that we
just leave it as it is some of the
values that you would be modifying is
for example the debug value
now when the debug value is true which
in our case it is whenever an error
occurs in any of your code and you're
trying to run that page all the arrows
appear on the page but now if you are
putting your website into the real world
you do not want that all your errors
will be displayed on the page for
obviously security reasons so then you
can just change this value to false just
before you upload your page next you
have the URL speech as from the name it
very clear the URLs page is where you
have your URL stored so basically this
file Maps the URL of a page to the
function of the page will be performing
so now you have the WSGI dot py code
file so this page contains an
application callable which the
application server uses to communicate
with your code and finally we have the
managed or py page this is the page used
to interact with your project so we
never ever touch the managed or py page
the settings page does change when your
website goes into the teal world the
URLs page we will be actually modifying
during the course of our project
again the wsg y dot py page believeth
untouched so now that you know the
basics of what each file already present
does we can start a demo so before we
start coding our website there's a dummy
development server which is provided
with Django
so we'll just check that out first just
go to your command prompt and move into
the path of your project and then you
just type Pythian manage dot py grunt
server and as you can see here the
development server has started and it's
at put 8000 so go to your browser open
any browser of your choice localhost and
at 8000 put and as you can see here
since we have installed our Django and
we're on a server so our Django page has
appeared here and says that our
installation worked successful so so far
all good we can now start building a
project so what website are we creating
well I was thinking of a very basic
website where you'll have the front page
the first page would have probably like
3/4 Jonas and within each owner you'll
have a piece that is an article an oval
or even a poem of that particular genre
so the user gets to click the genre on
the first page and the minute he or she
does so we move on to the next page
where we have an article within that
genre displayed will also include a
registration page just to see how that
works with Django so before we move on
guys I want to tell you that this
tutorial will completely concentrate on
how Django works so we will know
look much into the details of how our
page is displayed that is we won't go
in-depth into HTML CSS and so on but
rather just stick to Django and its
functionality and another thing that we
need to know about Django before we
start developing is that every page in
Django is called an app so when you go
to our website say Facebook for instance
you have multiple tabs right so there's
a tab for the profile you click on it
and it immediately takes you to your
profile now if this entire thing that is
Facebook was built on Django then your
profile would be one app and then
there's another tab which takes you to
your messages the page where all your
messages are displayed that would be a
second app so that's how Django works
every small thing every continent or
every page of your website is an app and
you need to ensure that you can describe
exactly what an app does in one or two
sentences so a page should not have
multiple things happening on it if a
page is for displaying messages that
should be the sole purpose of the page
so yeah that's the basic of apps and how
they are a part of Django so how do we
create this app just open your command
prompt move on to the path where your
projector stood now in here
you'll type in the command to create
your first app so that's Python manage
dot py start app and then the name for
your app so I'll need my absalom so
basically on my first page I want all my
runners to be displayed and every
article is put under a particular genre
hence the name enter and your app should
be created so I go back to my Python and
as you can see here we have a optional
created in iam now under this app there
are more number of files so what are
these files do we'll discuss that first
well first is our migrations folder now
inside this migration folder there will
be a number of files which will be
created once we go through our project
we will see every time we execute a
particular command a new file is
inserted into the my creations folder so
this basically connects your database
with your source code and that might
seem very complicated but actually
Django makes it extremely easy and then
you have the admins page now this admin
file or this admin
Paige that Django provides is extremely
useful it's like the Samy admin page
where you can actually go and you can
view your entire database there in a
very formatted way you have all the
models that you created them
you can insert more values you can
delete values you can edit values which
are already present so right now the
admin page will not be existing there's
no point of us going and checking it
right now since we have not created any
models yet again what is models I'll
come to that too so that is the next
file I'll be telling you about now if
you have gone through object-oriented
programming Python or Java or any other
object-oriented programming as a matter
of fact you probably know the concept of
classes now over here in our models file
we create classes and each of this class
is actually a mod and by that we mean
it's a database so when we created class
we have a number of attributes in this
class and each of this attribute forms a
column in our database so that is what
will be happening here and once we
create a class or what we call model
that is when we can actually view the
admin page and we'll see how this page
is extremely helpful
the next important page is the views
page so guys if you remember initially I
told you that Django has a design
pattern which is the Model View template
where model is already discussed there
are the classes template as you probably
guessed is the look of the page so
that's basically HTML files and what
brings the model and the template
together that is the view so view adds
the functionality now whenever you
receive a request from the user for a
particular URL view will describe the
response for this request but view is
not responsible for giving the response
that is another file that we'll be
creating as you'll see in some time so
now when I go back to my web page sure
there's no URL for this this is just a
domain name but once we start creating
our website the very existence of each
web page is linked to a presence of a
URL so that is exactly where we start
building under a Django project folder
we have this URLs page there's already a
URL path present here
it says admin which is as you guessed
it's the URL to the admin page that is
by default provided by Jango and over
here there's this another parameter so
what this parameter is it's the response
that is to be given for the requests
that you receive
now just in this manner we need to add
the URL for our first page which is
gonna be the genres page say say path
you shown us and then in here I'll
insert the action so have not created
any action yet so I don't know what to
put in the either as of now but guys
think about this
so if our website has 10 pages does this
mean that we'll have 10 different URLs
going in here that would be quite half
asad wouldn't it so we need a more
organized way of doing this and for that
very purpose we will use genres the app
as our base app so if from genres we are
moving on to our second page so say our
Jonas has our three genres which is
fiction inspiration and something else
through user clicks on fiction and this
immediately takes the user to the second
page where the content in fiction is
displayed so then our second page should
be a subpage of genre in a way and every
other page that we move to from our
first page should be the same so for
this purpose what we can do is we'll go
to a Jonas app the package we will
create another URLs file within genre
and in this URLs file we will define the
URL for a second page with reference to
our Jonah's URL so how is that done well
the first thing you need to do is you
must copy/paste the statement here into
our URL speech for this page we do not
really need to import include so I'll
remove that part out and I also need to
define my URLs pattern so copy-paste
this too but again admin is already
defined there completely we do not
require that now here we'll same if the
user wants the page on us this is going
to be my first page that is my front
page so what will be the response to
this the response will obviously be
defined in our views page right now we
have not created anything in our views
page but we will soon and we will
the response for the URL Jonas as index
since that is usually what the purpose
of the front page is it's usually to
display the index so we'll have view dot
index and then following this will also
give a name to this very particular call
and the purpose of that I will explain
later
just named this index for now it's not
view its views and also we need to now
import views okay so we define that if
the user goes to the space runner then
we will be displaying whatever us
defined under views dot index of course
we have not created that yet and we'll
move on to that in a while now the
problem is every request that is made by
the user
the first thing Janko does is it checks
the urls page under your main project
which is this page and under this page
we have not defined the action for
Honor's and it would be very repetitive
to define this again so what we do
instead is we just include the file
where we did define the function for
Honor's and that is Janos short URL s so
the user gives a request for the Jonas
page Jango checks out this main URL
speech it sees it matches the URL to
this very particular pattern here and
for that it knows that the response is
to include these honors dot URL page so
it includes this page and within this
page we of course have the function or
the response defined so now the next
thing is to create the response so now
under this views file we'll create a
view the first thing is we need to
import the HTTP package the request is
always HTTP and this time the response
that we are providing is also HTTP
response we'll change this later because
we will need a more defined response but
for now we will stick to a very basic
display on our first web page so let's
import Django dot HTTP import HTTP
response and now we can define a
function which will tell what response
to provide for the particular urls
now here we say that if the user gives a
request for this URL our responses views
dot index so within views we need to
define a function name
index so def index and this one takes
requests as a parameter and returns our
HTTP response and that response could be
a simple text of course you can also
have HTML tags and just for the purpose
of formatting so that our text looks
pretty bold I will put this into our
header just say hello world so that's
done this is the response that we'll be
providing for that particular URL now
the thing is we have this page her
settings and in settings if you scroll
down you'll see there's a list of apps
which are installed and in this list I
ABS onna
is not mentioned so before we run our
server will add our app to this list so
that's done now go to your web page the
one where you ran your localhost first
and this time okay so my server's not
running I need to start my server first
type in your command by thin manage dot
py run server and it says that there is
no issue and our server is currently
running so you go back to the page where
we ran a localhost
so the last thing we ran a localhost
currently your page would still be on
that if you have not done any
modifications I did a few in between
hence I got this page now if you check
out localhost again you'll see that
there's an arrow this because now we
started defining the URLs in our URL
page so when you don't give any URL as
such django checks out the two urls
defined here and sees hey what you typed
in here whatever your request was does
not match any of the URL patterns so now
we want to check out the show notes page
and enter and as you see here hello
world is displayed so of course this is
a dummy page we need to do something way
more we need to create a web page and
that is what we'll get to ok so now that
we viewed a dummy web page the next
thing we need to do is actually populate
this app with some data now to populate
the app with data of course we need to
first store the data and that is stored
in a database so with Django you would
have probably already noticed here
there's this file called SQLite 3 so
this is the database management system
that comes along with Django it's
already set up to be used just as
all command a small tweak that we
require and everything will work
perfectly fine so what this does is
basically all the data that you entered
through your model will work along with
this so that means that there should be
a communication between your SQLite and
your source code now if I go back to the
terminal where I'd LAN my server you'll
see here there's an error line which
says you have 15 unapplied migrations
and your project may not work properly
right now what we designed logged right
because we didn't have any data stored
but from now on we will be storing data
so we need to ensure that the migrations
are done right and by migrations we mean
that our database management that SQLite
is synced pretty well with our source
code so first of all stop your server
and now you'd run a command to do the
syncing which is Python manage dot py
migrate and as you hit this command the
syncing is happening so when you see
that the migrations are complete what
you actually mean is when Jango looks at
your installed apps this is an app that
we created and we just added it a while
back to this list of installed apps but
everything else in here in this list was
already present so these are some
default apps with Django or this project
in particular will already work with and
many of these apps require to access
some databases it could not do that
until now but now that we finished our
migrations when Django checks out these
apps and needs to run them it can easily
access the database take whatever data
is required from there and perform its
functions again if we go back to a
command prompt and run the server again
you see that this time we do not get the
error of the unapplied migrations so
that is how you sync your database with
your source code now once we create our
models it means that we have added some
new classes there are some new tables
which are going to be added so again we
need to perform the migration function
which we look into later now let's get
to creating our classes so as I
mentioned earlier models are basically
classes now there are two classes that
we will be creating for this particular
project the first class will have all
these honors
and the second class which should hold
all the articles so let's begin coding
now my first class I'll call it
collection and every class needs to
import from models dot model now within
this class all we need to define our H
various attributes so I'll explain this
again the class is basically a table and
all your attributes of the particular
class are the columns so the first thing
is the collection name or the Jean on E
now the collection name would be
something like a fiction or inspiration
or nonfiction could be anything and all
these are strings so when you're
inputting them so in Django basically
that's the cash field type so you see a
models dot kr field and a compulsory
parameter here is you have to insert the
maximum length
I'll give it hundred characters next
thing we'll have a description for each
gianna type that again would be careful
enter a max length give it 500 and then
we'll also have an image or a cover for
each of the collection or each of these
Yano so that would be a take called
cover as in collection cover so this
again will be a clear field type as I'm
going to enter the link for the image
over here now the links would be pretty
large so I'd say a length of thousands
so that's our first class
now we'll define a second class which is
for the particular articles or the
pieces which are inside the collection
so here we'll just go for one article
within a collection and I'll name this
class as piece as in a piece within a
collection again this class to impose
your models dot model and we will enter
the column names now so every piece will
have a title which would be the name of
the piece and that too would be of care
field type give the sir 200 and then all
of these will have a particular type
that is whether it's a book it's an oval
it's a poem or it's a blog post that is
what will go in a type variable next
we'll have the artist name for a book
that would be an author for a poem that
would be a poet so we'll go for the
general term which is artist the year it
was published
now the heel would be an integer so we
have a different feel type here the
integer field and that does not require
a Mac sling and finally again for each
piece you'll have a cover so I'll name
that please cover again we'll pass the
link of an immature so care field with
the max length of thousand and yeah
so our two models are created here class
collection and class piece now once
again we'll do the migration and what
will happen is that the database will
link with this model and then we can
finally view the admin page and see what
exactly that admin page is that we've
been talking about all this while but
before we move on we are missing out on
something so we have a collection and we
have each piece how do we link the piece
with the collection well this is where
the concepts that you probably learnt in
database is gonna come into use this is
where we use a foreign key so although
we're writing a code here this is
exactly how a table in a database will
be created so every item would have a
primary key and now we are going to use
foreign keys in our class piece to link
each piece to a particular collection so
if I say Dan Brown's book origin so that
should be linked through the foreign key
with our collection fiction so let's
create a foreign key and unnamed
collection but this time with a small
seat models dot foreign key so - the
foreign key you pass the table name to
which you're making the reference first
which is collection and then you pass on
an action as to what will happen to a
particular piece if the collection that
it's linked to is deleted so what we
want is if suppose fiction is deleted
then automatically origin which is tied
with fiction should also be deleted and
that is called a cascade delete so you
say on delete models dot cascade and now
we are finally done creating our models
so now that our models are created we
know these particular models are created
for our application or our app genre so
you go back to the settings page and
here we had previously inserted this
Zana but back then it was not Schiele
required it was just that there is this
other app that is not included in the
default apps given by Django so let's
put in the name there but now that we
actually have a database associated with
this app we need to specify this app in
its complete structure that is the
configuration so if you go under Jean us
and then there's this file apps and
under apps you can see this class Jean a
convict copy this go back to settings
so Jean or dot apps dot Jean a config so
now when you run your server Django will
check the list of installed apps and
you'll be able to access the database
associated with our newly created up to
but there's more to it than that
remember how previously we made
migrations so we can link our database
with the source code now we got to make
those migrations again because now we
created new models so every time you
create a model or you make some changes
to your models you always need to do
your migrations and this time since our
migrations are specific to a particular
app the syntax is slightly different you
can also use this terminal down here it
works just the same and piped in managed
dot py make migrations and your app name
enter and as you see it says the models
collection and piece have been created
now what this migrations exactly does is
it converts these models that you've
written encoded format into an SQL form
so that's where your tables and
everything stowed and now if you check
your migrations folder you'll see
there's a new file under it that is a
car in my creation that you attempt it
so now that the migrations are made you
can finally run your project so once
again and over all migrations so I'm
back to my command prompt since the
black background makes it easier to see
the text break out of your server and we
finished a migration so now we can run
our server Noah shows and there's no
error with the migrations either let's
now check out our on a page of course
it'll look
same because although we created our
models what the models will be reflected
in is the database the overall look of
the page so far has not been changed so
it's the same so I'll repeat that once
again every time you make a change to
your model or you add some new class to
your model first run the migrations for
that particular app that is fightin
managed or py make migrations and your
app name and then you run a migrations
in general so that's Python managed or
py migrations and then you can run your
server okay so our database is created
but right now it's empty so a next step
is to populate a database for that again
open a command prompt and now you need
to enter into the SQL shell so the
command for that is Python manage dot py
shell but before that I'll just go to
the path where my project is stored and
now in here I'll execute my command so
once you get these three arrows you know
that you have entered the shell and over
here you can execute your SQL commands
now before we input values into our
tables what we need to do is we have to
import these tables because even within
this project there are multiple number
of tables there are some tables which
were in there by default - so from genre
dot models import collection come up
peace which are the name of our tables
and enter so our tables are now imported
now first we populate our table
collection okay so collection has three
columns there's the collection name
there's a description and there's a
cover image so go back to your shell so
we'll have an object here collection one
which will be equal to collection so
this would be the constructor for our
class collection and within this we'll
insert our values
so our first attribute is collection
name and that's equal to fiction our
second attribute is the description and
we'll say enter the world of fantasies
for the description of fiction and
finally we have the attribute called
cover which is the collection
and in here I'll just enter the URL of
an image I found online so that's it we
have entered the values for our three
attributes now press Enter
now let's view if this actually stored
in a database so for that you execute
the command your table name which is
collection dot objects dot all and it's
empty
so what's wrong we created an object in
which we inserted all the values but
then still our database seems to be
empty so this is because so far this
collection object that we created is
only stored in our shells memory we have
not actually committed this to the
database so the command for committing
this to the database would be our object
name which is called one dot Save and
once again we'll execute the command to
check everything that's present in our
database collection and now you can see
finally that there is an object present
and now we can also check the value of
the various columns in our table
collection for this particular object
you can say call one dot collection name
and gives you the collection name
similarly you can also check its
description now as I mentioned
previously every object that you create
in a table has a primary key associated
with it so the primary key basically
holds a uniqueness of that particular
row so we can also check the primary key
for a particular row or an object just
go for call one dot P K and it says the
primary key is one now the primary key
is also known as the ID of the object so
you can identify it as ID two again
you'll get the value which is one now if
you want to change the value of any of
these columns that can also be done very
easily on the shell so suppose I want to
change the description say call one dot
description and initially it was enter
the world of fantasies I wanted to be
welcome to the world of fantasies so
welcome to the world of fantasies and
now if I check the value of : or
description the value has changed so
that's pretty simple isn't it now if you
think this is simple there is a much
much more simpler
way of adding values to the data piece
which we'll see just in a while and that
is where we put in more objects we'll
have a few more genres and we'll also
add elements to our table piece so now
we can look into how to create our admin
page so now that we learned how to input
or populate our database through the
shell let's go for the easier and the
more efficient way which is through the
admin now before we do that we need to
create our admin and for that go to your
command prompt out of the shell now in
your command prompt type the command
Pythian manage dot py create super user
ok so once you do that they'll ask you
to create a user name and we'll just go
for admin since we are creating ourself
as the admin enter enter an email ID
just go with admin 1-2-3 at admin calm
and a password so since this is not a
production environment I'm gonna just
bypass the password validation but if
your website is going into the real
world then make sure things are secure
enough and our super user is created
successfully so now we can go on to a
browser and here we will just type admin
so this is a admin page you can see here
there are two tabs groups and users but
the main thing the main reason that we
require the admin page does not seem to
come out here we expected there to be
our database tables present here so we
can directly go and edit them or add
some values to them but it's not there
so what is missing is that we need to go
back to a Python page and over here go
down to the admin file so here we need
to add the models that we want to appear
in the admin page basically we need to
register those models with the admin
page and for that the first thing we do
is we have to import the model so from
dot models import and our two classes
are collection and piece so we have not
added anything to our table piece yet we
will later on but any how we'll just
register both of them at one shot and
you
I've been here admin dot site dot
register collection copy-paste this and
change the collection to peace which is
our second table and that's it so with
just these two lines of code you should
have your collection and your piece
tables appearing in the admin page now
when I move back to the admin page and
refresh this you'll see that our tables
have appeared here click on collection
and there's one collection object here
click on that you can see the values of
the attributes and through this admin
page now I'll show you how you can add
more objects so just press on save and
add another here we can enter our second
collections name which in my case is
inspiration and description would be be
inspired to do more and for call cover
which is the collection cover I have
another link that I just took from the
net save and we'll add one more so we'll
have three collections now and a third
collection would be harder the
description let's say the fear is real
although we hope it's not and finally we
have the collection cover paste the link
here save this too so now we have three
objects under collection now as you see
here all our collection objects just say
collection object with the number in
bracket in the similar manner when we
were also going through our shell every
time we executed the command collection
dot objects dot all we got just the name
collection object and a number but we
want something more meaningful so when I
look at this table of collections I know
that the first one is the collection
fiction the second one is the collection
inspiration and so on so for that go
back to your code so go under your
models dot py file and under the class
collection we'll define a special method
which is double underscore STR now this
is an overriding method that is this
method already defined but the value
returned by this method is not of much
meaning to us as if now so now
here we'll return something that we
actually want to see when we look at the
objects in our table collection and what
I want is I want the collection name to
appear that would be quite clear as to
what object is at which position so I
say collection returned self dot
collection name and that should do it
now in the similar manner we can have
the same function for peace too and for
peace what we want to return is the
title so that's it now if I go back to
my admin page to refresh this as you can
see we have something much more
meaningful under our table collection
now the objects actually have a name
well the objects don't actually have a
name but we are displaying one of the
attributes of the object and that gives
no clarity as toward the object holds so
now we'll start creating our views now
as I mentioned earlier our website will
be such that the first page that the
user goes to is probably going to be
Dijon or speech which will have the URL
Jean or slash and with nothing following
it so the function for that particular
URL or the response for that particular
URL we defined in here in our urls page
under the Shauna's app witches will be
calling the index function in views that
is this function now from that page
there will be certain links and when the
user clicks those links he or she can
move to another web page and that is the
web page where the particular article
present inside our collection would be
displayed so I'll just put down in
comment what pattern of the URL we are
matching for each of these part so the
first one that we are matching is Joe
Jonah followed by nothing now our next
part would be Jonah followed by a number
now this number 1 here is actually the
ID of the collection that the user
chooses so if the user chooses the
collection fiction which is a first
collection that has a primary key 1 so
immediately the user should be sent to
the next web page which is your know
slash one where one represents the ID of
the collection chosen by the user so now
for part let's pass the expression that
will matter
this particular URL and that expressions
actually just an integer number since
the front part that is Jana slash is
already matched and this integer number
we are going to store it in a variable
because we require that variable later
so you can just see int : and collection
ID now when you do this
and Jonas IDs so when you do this what
happens is that this one gets stored in
this variable jean or ID and this
pattern will match this URL now when
this URL is matched what response do you
want to give that is what you want to
display on that particular webpage that
will be defined in another function will
define under views will name it details
for now of course details is not defined
we'll do that in a while and give a name
to this to which will be the same
details so now we are able to recognize
this URL what we need to do is next we
need to define details which will give a
response to that URL so go to your views
page and you create your details
function now what is displayed in this
details function greatly depends upon
the genre that is chosen by the user in
the first page which is stored again in
genres ID so over here you pass not only
the requests but also Jona ID and inside
he'll return our HTTP response the
collection the genre ID is the HTML tags
also need to be within the quotes copy
paste that in here half code here too
and now one more thing we need to do is
so Jonas ID is an integer but we cannot
concatenate an integer with the string
so we need to convert this to a string
and that's it so let's go back to our
web page and run this page so the first
page which is jános displays hello world
now if I enter John or slash one which
is what we created newly from the code
you see here the genre ID is one in a
similar manner even if I enter five
although we don't have a collection 5
will display the genre IDs 5 now these
dummy webpages so this kind of a display
is fine of course once we actually start
building of you which we will do very
soon things will be more defined now
let's get to actually creating a good
view so what we want here is first of
all we do not want to display any large
text so let's delete that off we need to
import our models because this is where
our database is and of course we need to
fetch information from a database to be
displayed on our view so from dot models
import collection and piece now in our
index function what we'll do is we'll
first collect all the objects from our
table collection we'll have a variable
which is all collection and then to
collect all the objects will use the
same SQL command that we used
so that's collection dot objects so all
your objects in the collection table
will be stored in oil collection now we
will store this as a dictionary so that
we can iterate over these objects and
display them one by one so we say
context equal to all collection is the
key and the value would be a variable
all collection so that's done now we
need to iterate over this so do we do
that within our views itself but there's
no point of doing that because while
we're iterating over every object in our
collection table we also need to display
them in a certain format that means that
we need these objects to be somehow
embedded in a HTML file and this is
where we create our very first HTML file
for a first page which is the Jonah's
page so to create a HTML page inside
Janome create another package and you
name this package templates now inside
templates create another folder and give
this package the name same name as your
apni garage owner and now inside Jonah
we can create a HTML file I'll name this
file Joe no template so all our template
or a HTML files will be in this path ok
so
for we actually develop the Shona
template HTML file we'll go back to a
view and complete the section of so now
what we're seeing is that we have a
template we have a HTML file and that
file will define how we need to display
the objects in our collection database
or a collection table all we need to do
here in our index function is actually
passed these objects to our HTML file so
for this we have a function render and
before we actually use a function we
need to import the library Django dot
shortcuts under which we have this
function render this is already imported
on top and not see that so I'll just
remove that part out and now that you
have the render function you use that to
pass your object so what this render
function does is basically will pass
context to it it will type context with
the template name that we pass and it
will return our HTTP response object so
you pass your request you pass the path
to your template that is Yano
slash templates slash Yano slash your
template dot HTML so now you have passed
your template too and finally the object
which is context so that's pretty much
all you need to do for your very first
view under the views file now we need to
develop our journos template so for our
HTML file first thing we'll change the
title let's display our app name so in
this particular case since I'm making a
dummy website and not giving it a name
or anything just going with our app name
okay so now we need to display our
objects which have been passed from the
views folder now the render function
basically passes an object which is
called object underscore list so we'll
create a for loop sake collection in
object underscore list so this way we
can iterate through all the objects in
our object list and now see this is an
HTML file but this line of code here
this is a Python code so pretty often
this will happen that you need to M
a Python code within your HTML file so
what you do is you insert your Python
code within curly brace followed by the
percentage sign this will tell you
compiler that here although this is a
HTML file this line here is actually a
Python instruction so now we are able to
extract a genre
in fact I'll name this variable as Jonah
obj now we need to decide how exactly we
want to display these objects so what I
want is first I want the image of that
particular collection or the genre to be
displayed which is what I have stored in
one of the variables and then just below
the image i1 the name of the genre to be
displayed now this name should be
clickable so that the minute the user
clicks on it we can move on to another
page and then just below the name
I want the description for that genre to
be displayed okay so first we have the
image IMG source and in here I need to
insert the link for that particular
image so the link I actually already
stored in my database as I should be the
dot through the shell and then later on
through the admin page too so how do we
access that particular link well just
like you would in a Python code you can
access it through the variable name and
every time you're accessing or you're
displaying just the value of a variable
you insert the variable name within
double braces so double braces and then
Zana obj dot called cover and now I'll
give it some height and width to make it
look a little more appealing
we'll have minimal formatting job
because the objective of this tutorial
is not to show you how to write your
HTML code
but how Django works and next I'll have
the name as I said this particular name
would be clickable so inside head chef I
will insert the URL of the page the user
should be taken to once he clicks on the
name so that URL is what we defined here
okay so it's Yano followed by the
primary key or the ID of the category
that he clicked so that would be Jonah
slash
and we stored it in Shauna ID so that's
the link the user will be taken to and
now the name that will be displayed and
then after that finally we have the
description to be displayed so that'll
be in a ch3 header again double braces
cuz we are going to just print out the
value of a variable and then after each
objects details are displayed we'll
break a line for better formatting what
I'll do is I'll have all of this
embedded within a div and have it
aligned to the center so that's it we
have created our HTML file here one more
thing I'll just say and for so that's it
a hash table file or are complete
display for the first page has been
created so once again I'll explain what
will happen in the case of a first page
only when the user enters the URL slash
genre followed by nothing
Ranko will first check this URL speech
the main URL page it will see the path
has matched here and the action for this
has been defined as you include the
genres dot URL page so it goes to the
Gianna's dot URL page includes this and
in this there is a function defined as a
response for this particular URL a very
well defined function which is in our
views file so it goes to the views file
and in the views file we have completely
defined our function index over here we
collect all the objects in our
collection table we convert that into a
dictionary so that it's iterable then we
pass it using the render function so the
render function will take your template
and we'll tie that along with the
context which is the dictionary and it
will pass an object a response object to
a head tml file this response object
will be called object dot list and it is
iterable so we'll iterate through the
object we will display each object in a
sort of formatted way and that is it and
then the render function will pass this
object all collection to our template
and over here we will iterate
over the oil collection which is the
dictionary and using this hash table
code here will print out the objects in
oil collection and a formatted wave so
that's it and one more thing make a
small correction back in the views file
so initially I had inserted the entire
path to Jean or template dot HTML so the
thing with the render function is that
it automatically knows that it must look
into the templates folder so you have to
only give the part after the template
that gianna slash on a template now
let's go back to our browser and in here
put in your URL and there you go so
that's our first web page can see the
image for our Jonah is here and then you
have the name and then you have the
description okay so that's redirecting
us to a page where there's an error that
says that this part is not found so when
you look at these error guys you will
understand better as to how the matching
of the URL patterns take place first
this URL pattern just this part after
your port number that is checked against
the URL in your main URL file that is
Django projects dot URL file where we
have defined J Jonah and then after that
it will check the files that we included
in the journos URL file that is Jana
followed by the leshawna ID now we had
defined a dummy page for this previously
and that was being displayed too so I'll
go back to the code and figure out what
the error is the error is here of course
I wrote Jonah ID which does not signify
anything as such now because here we
have this object Jonah
obj that is where all the objects from
the collection table are stored one by
one so what we actually need to access
is the ID for Jonah obj now I'll go back
to my browser so now I'm back to my
browser and as you can see here we still
have our front page click on fiction and
yeah we got a dummy page back so now our
next step is to decide
this page go back to your code and again
designing the page means we need to
start putting content into our details
function now before we start designing
this function we need to populate the
peace table so again let's go back to
our admin page we'll add the data
through the admin page since that's much
easier here you have peace and click on
the Add button first we add for fiction
the title will give let's insert the
book origin by Dan Brown so the artist
would be done round and it's an oval and
the year is 2017 that's the year of
publication and for the piece cover I'll
just put the book origins front page
cover I just put in the image here a
link save and add another now for
inspiration I'll put in the poem if and
type would be poem artist is Rudyard
Kipling's Kipling with single P the year
of publication would be 1895 and for the
piece cover another link and finally
we'll add one to horror the title would
be the pet symmetry written by Stephen
King and again this is a novel it's
published in the year 1983 and then
linked and we save this so we are done
for each of the categories or each of
the genre we have added a single article
so now that our table piece is also
populated we can start designing the
view for this so for our details page
let's start with removing this hedge ttp
response here so first what we need to
do is we need to extract the object that
the user selected from our genres page
so we say collection dot objects dot get
PK equal to Shana ID so what we're doing
here is as you can see above we use the
query collection dot of
jigs dot all which returned all the
objects in our table collection now here
we are telling that okay I want just one
object from my collection stable and
that particular object is the one whose
primary key matches that stored in the
variable genre ID and since Jana dot ID
is defined in this file and it's
basically the ID of the genre that the
user selected this will be a number
either 1 2 or 3 that is 1 for fiction -
for inspiration and 3 for horror so now
that we got that object we will use this
object see item to extract from up piece
table so for that we say peas dot object
dot filter and to this we pass and the
category that we filter on is the
collection and that is a foreign key so
remember when we created our table piece
we had a foreign key named collection so
we're seeing if collection is equal to
see item then extract that particular
object from our table piece and then we
will return this again through the
render method pass the request and in
here we'll have the path to an HTML file
just like we did in the previous case by
this time a different HTML file because
we want to display this slightly
differently and then finally we need to
pass the context so we haven't created
the context yet which we will now
although this is just one item every
time you are passing it through the
render function you need to make a
dictionary out of it so just copy paste
this here name this P item pass in here
P item
just now I did create a hedge tml file
in the same path as before that is under
templates you have the genre folder and
under that I created a hitch table file
called detailed template
nothing's filled yet but now that we
have created a file we can put in the
path here so just copy paste this and
she is the genre to detail so that's
done too
now all we have left is to actually code
the HTML file so I'll just copy paste
this here and then make the required
correction so in pea item and this would
be piece object you align it center and
piece obj is the cover we do not really
need a head chef here so delete that
part out because this is the final page
we are not redirecting to any other page
from here of course when you building a
complete web page this ideally when you
click on the name of an article the
article should open we wouldn't be
including that part here though cuz it
does not bring out any new functionality
of Django piece obj and here so piece
obj dot title - and then we'll print out
the author or the artist name so piece
obj dot artist and finally we can have
the year also what this particular
article is that is the type
so that's pretty much it will change the
title too
[Music]
so now that this is done we'll just end
the for-loop
also this is called cover but now we
could change it to peace cover and now
we'll go back to a browser so the sir
Jonah page the flesh at once again and
we'll click on one of the Jonas and yeah
as you see the particular piece later to
that Jonah gets displayed the patch
symmetry by Stefan King which is an oval
published in the year 1983 so now we're
back to a court and well a first and a
second page is designed it's working
fine so now we are not going to create
something new instead what is already
created let's modify that now so far the
functions that we wrote work just fine
but Django provides this thing called
generic classes or generic views what
this does is it makes writing these
functions extremely easy so now you have
four lines of code the exact same thing
can be done in like two or three lines
of code in fact it's not just the easier
method this is also recommended so I'll
tell you how that is done
first of all we need to import the
generic package so from Django dot views
import generique and now let's delete
this entire thing
so our first function is basically
listing out all the objects in the table
so you have multiple objects all of them
are being listed out now this kind of a
function put belong to a generic class
so far I was defining functions now I'm
speaking about class so is it a function
or a class well it is a class it's
definitely a class but I'll show you how
this class is called as a function
so first we'll finish writing the class
now we have the class index and this
particular class type is a list view
because you're listing out objects now
under this first we'll have a template
name which is the path to a template
and now to return our query set so
previously we were always returning a
dictionary now we can return a query set
we have a function def query set and
under this we just say return collection
dot objects dot all the same query we
were using previously but now we do not
need to take the objects from the query
and then convert them into a dictionary
then pass it on
using the render function we can simply
do this one statement and all our
objects will be sent to a template we're
now in the template so far we were
seeing all collection because that is
the key that we were using in our
dictionary but that is no more we are
not using the render function anymore
when this query set passes an object
it's received by the template file in a
variable named object list so you
replace your previous variable with
object list and that is it with that we
finished the method for displaying our
first page now we'll move on to the
second page so the second page is
slightly different because this time we
are not listing out multiple objects we
just have one object and we are
basically giving out the details of the
object that means that this class
which we'll still call details is a
detailed view class so we say gender ik
dot detail view
let's delete all of this first now the
function of this detailed view is
basically to display the details of an
object so what we need to do is first we
need to define a model now our model is
collection because we are receiving the
primary key from the collection and each
of this object actually is a part of a
collection the object would not exist if
they related or the counterpart genre of
that object did not exist so a model is
collection and our template name will be
again the part so that jean of detail
template dot HTML and that's it
so this is even smaller than our gender
equal now in a detail template initially
we had the name of the key in our
dictionary again this time we don't have
a dictionary pass so what is the value
here well the value here would be
collection dot piece underscore set dot
all so this will return all the pieces
related to that particular collection
and everything in small this time now we
are almost done go back to your views
and you see this is a generic detail
view now the thing about the detailed
view class is it always accepts one
parameter go back to your URLs file as
you are passing your a variable gen
genre underscore ID of in type you don't
need to do that anymore you can simply
say piqué and piqué will be passed to
this class and now that's the problems
so here we were calling functions but
now we have classes defined not
functions anymore so we need to figure
out a way of calling this class as a
function so for that you just say as
underscore view for both of these
classes
and that's it as simple as that now you
can call your classes as a function and
since you use the generic view now
things have become so much more simpler
much smaller our code looks very neat
now let's go back to our browser guru
front page let's see if everything is
displayed right yes it is so a changes
worked out just fine
click on one of these tags and as you
can see the page has loaded so much less
code very few lines of code but things
work just as fine as before so web page
is all built but let's add something new
over here to make it look a little more
like a website one of the most common
things that you find in every website
you go to is a navigation bar so let's
add the navigation bar go back to your
code now in here we need a navigation
bar in both our pages so typically what
you might think is the way to go about
it is add the code for navigation bar in
your genre template and detailed
template but as you know whenever you
could repeatability is something that
you should be always against minimum
repeatability so instead what we do is
under Zana the same folder that has all
our templates create another HTML file
and name this base so this will be a
base template and we will add the code
for creating a navigation bar in here
and then we'll just include this base in
our other templates so first let's
create our navigation bar now we'll be
using bootstrap to create the navigation
bar and every time you work with
bootstrap the first thing you need to do
is in your head section include these
three links so if you work with
bootstrap you probably already know you
need to go to the bootstrap website copy
these links paste them here so you're
basically able to access some style
sheets which are stored in some other
system and once that's done you can
start building your navigation bar
senior body
have nav class
navbar and nav bar default
so this is the class for creating your
basic navigation bar but actually will
go with inverse instead of default so
this has a dark theme navigation bar it
will look better on a white background
website within this create a div tag of
container fluid so basically what the
container fluid does is that your
navigation bar will occupy the entire
page and will fit according to the page
width now under this you have the nav
bar brand class
and if first I can I want is my home
okay so I put in home here and when I
click on whom whatever I want to be
redirected to whichever page I want to
be redirected to put the link for that
or the URL for that in here and I'd like
to be redirected to the journals page
since that's our home page
now other elements we can include in a
navigation bar we put them as list
elements so class nav nav bar and we
want these elements to the right of a
navigation bar so we say nav bar right
now I'm not going into the details of
this since again this is not a part of
the Django tutorial so we'll quickly
just create the navigation bar now every
element to the right will be listed out
and I'll have a registration button so
that'll be under Jean or slash register
now I have not created the view for this
URL yet
in fact this URL is not even
identifiable yet but for now I'll just
put that in and we'll run it all
together
and finally at the very right and corner
of my navigation bar I want to display
the username that is whichever user is
currently going through my website now
yeah right now we have not designed the
features for all of this we don't have a
registration form itself so a user does
not mean anything to us right now but
very soon I'll show you how you can
create a registration form you can have
users register to it so then this will
start making sense
so we'll say elects loss and in here the
way you can extract the current user of
your website is you say request dot user
and that's it that's pretty much all we
need right now
just check all the tags again we have
the novel inverse which is the type the
look of our navigation bar container
fluid and here we actually need to
specify that it's a header so we same
diff plus
navbar header
when this would be closing right in the
end
so just format this once
and finally down here you insert two
python statements you see
block content our content is a variable
so you can have any other name here just
say block content and then end block so
write this I'll explain to you in a
while so basically this entire part
creates your navigation bar but you
require this navigation bar to be
present in multiple pages so here when
you say block content and end block it's
basically the content that will fall in
each of the pages so if I go to my genre
template page I can simply include the
base template here and then everything
inside these on a template page all this
instruction to actually create that page
will come under a block so what we'll do
here is we'll go to our template pages
and here we will extend our base dot
HTML file so extends Jean our slash base
dot HTML
and then the body the instructions
within the body will be the content of
the block CC block content
and then end block now we do the exact
same thing with our detailed template
so now this way we created a common base
file for a navigation bar and the
content for each of these templates will
be by turn included within this tag here
so we'll have the navigation bar present
for every page now when we move back to
a browser you see the change here there
is a navigation bar if you click on whom
will be redirected to a genre page and
then click on one of the categories and
you have been redirect to the next page
the navigation bar is still present so
we also have a user here currently the
only user we created the super user
it's the admin this will change soon
once we start registering people so next
step is to create a form where we can
actually have users register so for a
registration page the first thing we
need to do is we need to create a URL
and go in here let's copy this line
so the recognizable URL would just say
it register so it would be Jonas slash
register
and that would call a views function
called user form and we obviously
haven't defined this class yet so yeah
this is also going to be a class we are
gonna use the generic view to create
this tool it's going to be pretty simple
but since it's a class we need to call
it as a function so as view will still
exist and we here will have user form
but before we start actually creating a
view for the registration page or
writing a hash-table file we need to
create a blueprint for the form so why a
blueprint for the form when we did not
create a blueprint for our other pages
I'll tell you why
but first we need to comment this
particular line because it will result
in an error and now we'll check out our
admin page yes so this table here is
what we'll be using to store our user
names so the tables already present here
we'll just tweak it a little that is we
will take the user name we'll take the
email address and we will take a
password field all of these actually
have a password if you click on them you
can see here the password is hashed so
these are the three fields that will
collect from the user so we'll use the
basic form just selecting exactly what
we need so for that purpose we need to
create the blueprint so to create the
blueprint under Zana create a Python
file calling it forms
and now in here
we import that table we just saw that
database so we say Django dot contrib
dot or dot models import user
- imports here
and then we import the module phones
okay so now we can create a class called
user form which will import from forms
dot modal form
and in her we'll have a class called
meta so meta basically means the
definition or a description of your
class so inside a class userform will
have a description for a class and in
that description we give a model name so
model name is user cuz we'll be using
that particular model I just showed you
and then we'll specify the fields that
we'll be using from this model because
we are not taking all the fields we are
going to ignore a few of them so we say
fields create a list here and within the
list we enter the name of the attributes
that will be actually using for our
particular form so we have user name
email and we'll take a password now
unlike user name and email password is
not just any care field so over here we
have to specify the password type so you
say forms dot care field and within
brackets you say which it equal to forms
dot password input so password input so
from this your Django we'll know that
here we basically need to take the
hashed values and not just store what
the user inputs as characters
so that's it with that we have created
the blueprint of a form next thing is we
can actually go to the views and begin
writing the view the plus view for our
form so the class to create a form we
called user form view
actually before we proceed we need to
import this so let's do that first
import' userform also need to import
some other packages
here we'll import a few packages for use
authorization that's authenticate and
login
and now we can begin writing our user
forum of your class so - user forum you
you pass the object view and we also
need to import a class for this so let's
do that
Chango dot view store generic import
view
okay so the first thing we need to
define a class for this forum and that
would be the user forum and once again a
template for this forum which will
define the outlook this forum has so you
give a template name which is a variable
name actually you can have any variable
name here just something that makes
sense
now I don't have a temporary page
already I'm not isin have not created
another HTML file for the forum
specifically but I know that I'll be
creating it the path Shana slash and the
name of the HTML file so that would be
form template now the minute we are done
writing this view I'll show you how we
do the template that's just basic HTML
code so I'm pretty sure you know how to
work with that too now with forms there
are two things there's the get method
that is basically when the user wants a
form so you give the user an empty form
and there's a post method that is when
the user puts in his or her details into
the form so with our class with a
generic classes these methods are
already defined and within two three
lines you can completely define the
functionality of these so first is the
get method to which we pass self and
request
now the first thing is you provide the
form to the user and this form is empty
so you say self dot form plus and you
pass nothing to this because as I
mentioned earlier to the form is empty
and now what you do is you return this
object through the render function so
basically when you do this the form is
combined with the HTML file and an
object is returned so basically when you
do this what happens is as I mentioned
earlier to the render function works in
the same way it passes the object of the
form the content of the form to the
template and it basically sends out a
HTTP request
so that's your template name and then
finally deform itself
and as we did previously this will be a
dictionary and that is the gate function
now we'll move on to the post again you
pass self and request
now when the user enters the data and
then hits the submit button that's when
the post function will be called all the
data will be stored in a particular data
variable and that is what we will be
defining in the first line so for me
quill to self dot form plus
and request dot post so all your data
will go into this post variable
now the next thing that the post
function has to do is check if the data
entered by the user does make sense so
for that you see if form dot is valid
so if the form is valid save this data
so you say form dot save so where
exactly are we saving this well as I
showed you previously or Django provides
this table for user this database for
storing the users and the group users so
that is exactly where we'll be storing
the data received through this
particular form
now if the data is valid we can separate
out the various fields receive the clean
format so first we have a username say
username equal to form dot Clint data
and that will be username and then you
have the password
so remember when the user entered the
data itself it was stored in these
fields but now we're getting a clean
version of that data and storing it in
this these variables username and
password and now unlike how we can
usually put the equal to sign and assign
values to certain variables this kind of
a process is not possible for passwords
because passwords are not just storing
some cash field data it has a hash value
I'll show you that once again so you see
here you go to the users admin and if
you check this out
the password is not actually stored as
just characters its hashed using some
algorithm and then it's stored so in
this particular case we cannot say that
password is equal to this value there's
a certain function through which you
pass the password such that it's stored
in the required format so for that you
see user dot set password and then you
pass password variable and finally you
see user dot safe so guys over here
actually we are saving the data in the
shell not in your database and once our
data is cleaned and everything it is
then that we are saving it into the
database so that's why we have two safe
statements here so now that the user has
entered their data and they've hit the
submit button we have saved the data in
our database what's next well now what
we want to do is we need to redirect the
user to the index page basically once
the user is done with the registration
process there's no point of the user
staying on the same page again
so we redirect them to the index page
now along with this we'll also combine
login so if the users password and
username are authenticated and the user
is in active status that means that the
user has logged in to our website so now
we will see how this is done create a
object new user and this object will
hold a user if the username and the
password that we pass here to this
authenticate function is
valid and they match that is the form of
that is they form a pair so the username
will be the variable username and
password will be the variable password
so if the new user does exist that is if
new user is not null
if the new user is not none we'll check
these teachers of the new user so what
is the status again I'll take you back
to the database Curie users well since
we're in the middle of the code we
cannot access this page but basically
this database or this table with stores
the user names has a field called status
which you probably would have noticed
and next to the active user there's a
green tick so if the user has that green
tea if the user is active that means his
session is in progress so it's basically
like logging in
so you say if new user dot is active
your login the user she sent request and
the new user object and once the user
has logged in you return the user to the
index page and this is where you need to
use a function redirect before we use
that function we need to of course
import it
so here our redirect is within this same
shortcuts library we'll just add in
redirect here
so index page is basically called
journal so that's where the user will be
taken
now if this user is not authenticated
that is there is some invalid data
entered we basically give the user back
or form an empty form give them another
chance to fill it so for that we just
copy/paste this line here the render put
that down there
and that's it with that we are done
creating our view for our user forum now
what we are left with is actually
creating this hedge tml file so let's do
that again go to Jean Oh your main
folder and create a hedge tml file now
remember what we named a hash tml file
in this view that's form template make
sure the same name
so let's start creating the form the
first thing we do is for the form to you
want to add the navigation bar so go do
go to any of your HTML files and copy
out these lines here
registration
then you have the block content which is
exactly where you'll be putting all your
content that goes here and then we'll
start and then we'll add the end block
again copy a star - okay so now we can
start typing out a HTML code
so first is our form tag
now there's going to be an extremely
simple straightforward form
and now the thing with Django is
whenever you're having a forum and in
Traktor form make sure to include this
CSRF token here so CS are f stands for
cross-site request forgery that can be
sent actually from answer type of
cross-site scripting attack that can be
sent from malicious site through your
visitors browser to your own server so
to prevent this django provides a very
simple technique which is where you
provide this CSRF token now make sure
you're always providing this whenever
you have a post method and you're not
redirecting or you're not using the URL
of or you're not using an external URL
because that means that your current
page CSRF token is being sent to an
external web page and obviously that
kind of a leakage would hamper the
security okay so we'll be taking a
username
again email is also typed text
and finally the password
and after all the fields you have
finally submit button
and that's it so HTML page is also ready
now so now you need to move on to the
URLs page and uncomment this because now
we actually have a response also this
called user form view now
I'll just stop the server and run it
again although that's not really
necessary whew just go back to your page
refresh it everything works fine okay
now we will move on to our web page okay
so our home page is working fine just
like before next you click on register
and here's your form so as you can see
here the navigation bar is present for
the form tool now we will create a new
user name simply with the email ID
simply 1-2-3 gmail.com and a password
that's it now click the submit button
and the minute we click the submit
button as you can see you got
transferred back to the home page and in
here if you see the right-hand corner
you'll notice that we had admin before
but now it's simply so that is because
we just now created a user simply and
the minute you create a user by default
that becomes the active user now to
check this we will move on to the admin
page
and this is a landing page so now what
happened is that since the other user
that we newly created is the active user
that means we got logged out of the
admins profile and to view the admin
page of course we need to be logged in
as the admin so I'll log back in and as
you can see here under the users group
you'll notice we have a new user created
simply with the following email ID so
that's it guys so with that we come to
an end or tutorial on Django if you have
any doubts please leave them in the
comment section below and we'll
definitely get back to you also if you
liked the video please hit the like
button and also subscribe to our channel
if you haven't yet so keep learning and
see y'all next time
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here